all right so um we're going to talk
about number
i got a little carried away with the
behavioral work on number because i just
think it is so awesome
uh and i think it's frankly a little
more interesting than a lot of the
neural work so this is going to be sort
of a behaviorally heavy lecture
but let's start by thinking about
why why we have number and what we use
it for
and the first thing to realize is that
we use concepts of number and quantity
like all the time
most obviously if you're say getting
change at a store i guess that doesn't
really happen very much anymore people
are going to forget how to subtract
because they just put their credit card
or bump their phone or whatever they do
but anyway it used to be that you handed
over this stuff called money and that
coins came back and that it was the
subtraction involved
we use it to tell time uh or to fail to
tell time as in my case this morning
uh to choose the larger of two objects
that's a continuous idea of quantity not
a discrete idea of number
um to choose the shortest line at a
grocery store
right and all of those kinds of things
are comparing quantities
um
and we also take these basic ideas of
number and quantity and we build on them
in modern societies to do all kinds of
amazing things
like engineering
like all of modern science is highly
quantitative like all of computer
science
uh and so these are really fundamental
ideas
and
animals it turns out are capable of
mastering very simple
but sophisticated
understandings of number and even
even arithmetic computations
they can deal they can learn about order
and number and quantity
okay
and they need to for lots of reasons
um so here just a like brief overview of
some of the situations where animals
need concepts of number and quantity in
the wild
foraging right so animals spend a lot of
time kind of rooting around for food
over here rooting around for food over
there deciding when to keep rooting
around here despite diminishing returns
and go somewhere else where there's
unknown
payoff unknown amounts of food so that's
a whole this whole math of foraging
behavior
okay
so that deals with the you know rate of
return of the food at each location and
the amount and the quality and you can
imagine a whole math to optimize amount
of food they also need to know about
number and quantity when they form teams
which many animals across taxa do in
different ways
so schooling fish
can quickly pick out the more numerous
school of fish to join and that's what
they want to do because your statistics
are better if they're a predator if
you're in the larger school than the
smaller school
right
um
so your chance of getting eaten is
reduced just dividing by the number of
options
and then there's all kinds of animals
that take into account the size of
groups of their own species or other
species
when making um
decisions about uh you know how far to
run or who to chase and or who to
predate on or who's at risk of predating
upon you
um so
you know lions hunt in teams and they
have to work together they have actually
a whole strategic situation where
different lions play different parts
like a football game
um and they have to decide which you
know which groups of predators to take
on based on numerical advantage
uh and my favorite is the n plus one
frog the tungruck frog that lives in the
uh rain forest in puerto rico
um and it literally one-ups uh other
frogs the males do in trying to
impress the females and so what happens
is that one frog will start calling out
uh one male frog will start calling out
trying to sound all hot
to the gals and then another frog will
one ups him by doing that call but
elaborating on it by adding an extra
call or an extra component
so for example
okay so that's one dude calling out
and not to be
outdone the next guy calls back
and apparently
if you follow these guys they pretty
systematically add one to the previous
frog's call
right
up up to a point the point being
approximately four
so it's not
it's not like a hundred and 101 but
um
but it happens okay such a broad
overview of some of the cases that uh
that understandings of number and
quantity
um arise in natural environments without
training
so we want to know how is all this
computed
in the mind and brain
and so um one of the foremost thinkers
on this topic is stand ahead shown here
um and he wrote in a um very widely
cited uh
book actually review article in book
quite a while ago 20 years ago
he said animals young infants and adult
humans possess a biologically determined
domain specific
representation of number
so this is a very kind of extreme
hardcore claim
we will see at the end of the lecture
that he has backed off that claim
um okay so a couple things biologically
determined he's kind of implying innate
right
domain specific i've sort of avoided
this phrase for the most part because
it's kind of like jargon gobbledygook
but it's actually
so entrenched in our field that it's
worth knowing what it is domain specific
is just this idea of functional
specificity that i've been talking about
but you can apply it to not just a peach
piece of brain like does this patch of
brain process only faces you can also
apply it to a mental process even if you
don't know what its actual brain basis
is so do we have special mental
machinery for thinking about numbers
that's distinct from our machinery for
face recognition or navigation or
language or whatever else okay so that's
what domain specific means and it's
worth knowing because you'll encounter
it in other contexts
okay
so in more detail stan says
a specific neural substrate located in
the left intraprietal area
is associated with knowledge of numbers
and their relations which he defines as
number sense
the number domain is a prime example
where strong evidence points to an
evolutionary endowment of abstract
domain-specific knowledge in the brain
because there are parallels between
number processing in animals and humans
again kind of hardcore claims
not just is there this
so he doesn't quite say innate but he's
strongly implying innate i mean that's
you know evolutionary endowment that
basically means innate right it's an
evolved ability that lives in a
particular part of the brain okay
so who would have thunk right number
right you think of number is something
you get taught in school but no he's
saying it's really part of your
biological endowment it has a particular
brain region
uh and all of that may be um if not
completely independent and may exist
without explicit training
okay that's so that's quite a claim
so what does number sense mean exactly
well what stan and others in the field
mean by number sense it's a bunch of
things first of all the idea that
for human adults to have number sense
that means they can represent large
numerical magnitudes without verbal
counting
right so counting is an interesting
thing but we're going to leave it aside
for the moment number sense is a is a
more general idea that's going to apply
to animals and and infants without
explicit counting okay so you can have
some way of representing that there's a
lot of things here and there's fewer
things there
um second of all these representations
are approximate
um and the ability to discriminate two
of them depends on the ratio of those
two not the absolute difference okay
i'll show you in more detail what i mean
by that it's a deep fact about number
sense and actually all of perception
pretty much
um further the idea is that these
representations are abstract they're not
just say a particular visual form
like approximately 13 looks like this
no they're going to generalize across
modality okay and space and time
next
these
mental representations of number
can be used in operations even without
counting and knowing being explicitly
informed you can add approximate numbers
you may be thinking what the hell am i
talking about but i'll show you in a
second
so
for example
i'm going to show you two sets of dots
next and you're just gonna shout out
first if the first set of dots had more
had more if there were more dots in the
first array and second if the second
array had more dots okay ready here we
go
boom
um
second duh okay let's try another one
that you get another one
uh-huh another one
i noticed the volume decreasing and i
noticed some hesitancy
actually i'm not sure with that one
okay
so how did you do that
what'd you do
did you go one two three four five
no i tried to do it so there wasn't time
to do that how'd you do it i kind of
tried to see like the density like how
close all the dots
and did that work for you do that did
that work okay
it seems to be okay
okay what jack is pointing to is a
really important thing in thinking about
number which is that number is
confounded with area extent how much
total yellow stuff is on the screen
and it's confounded with density
and this is a big problem
in people who want to do research on
number and so what they usually do is
you can't totally unconfound those
things but you can unconfound them one
at a time so you can vary the size of
the objects and you can vary the density
across trials so no one of those cues
will enable you to do it fully i didn't
these this example isn't great that way
because they were all the same size
right
um
okay but so the point is without
explicitly counting and god knows what
you do it how you do it you just feel
like you have a sense of roughly how
many everybody got that sense okay so
that's what we mean by number sense is
that sense that you can just look at
something and have a sense of roughly
how many like you don't know if it's 19
or 18 but you know it's not
13.
right okay
um
right
oh and
you guys all got quieter when the
numbers got closer together okay gets
harder when the numbers are closer
together
okay so in experiments that have
quantified this lots of people have
looked at this here's one that i was
involved in way back just like you did
this is the task here that you guys just
did
and here's some of the data we got so
let me walk you through this this is
accuracy on a bunch of different
comparisons
16 dots versus 32 dots people are pretty
much 100 correct okay
this is just normal human adults
16 versus 24 great 16 versus 20 pretty
good
16 versus 18. now we're really dropping
16 versus 17 forget it can't do it okay
so performance falls off
as the numbers get closer together okay
so that's sort of intuitive
but now let's consider these are all
comparing um
to um to sixteen
here we compare to eight
eight versus sixteen eight versus twelve
eight versus ten eight versus nine you
see the same fall off as the numbers get
closer together
okay
so far so good
but now we can ask what determines that
falloff is it the absolute difference or
the ratio
and the way we tell
is we plot the ratio
of those two curves
and we look at performance and we see
they are spot on top of each other
that tells us that it is not the
absolute difference that determines your
ability to do this but the ratio of the
numbers of dots
okay it's sort of intuitive
right but it's amazing how clear the
result is everybody get that
okay so this is a really deep
fundamental fact
um about
perceiving number
approximate number and it's actually
more generally a fact about perception
it's called weber's law and it just
means that the discriminate
discriminability of in this case two
numbers two numerosities depends on
their ratio not their absolute
difference the exact same thing holds
for
evaluating which of two stimuli is
brighter which of two objects is heavier
which of two sounds is louder they all
follow uh the ability to do that is a
function of the ratio
of the two not the absolute difference
yeah
the size of the dots
and so in this experiment we um we vary
the sizes every which way and the
density as i mentioned before you can't
completely unconfound both size and
density within each trial but across
trials you can muck them up so you can
ask whether people are doing it by size
or by density okay
and and we did all that here
okay
so this is not shocking yet it's just
kind of a basic deep clear fact about
whatever our mental representation of
number is that it's it's this
approximate thing it's pretty good and
it um and it's precision scales with the
with the magnitude
okay
um
all right so the way so this has been
quantified in lots and lots of
experiments and this is called the
approximate number system or ans
um and the standard test that's been
used in lots of studies to measure
uh people's kind of number acuity is a
lot like what i just showed you you show
an array like this and you say are there
more yellow dots or blue dots
and people very quickly say yellow in
this case and then you ask for a case
like this and they're a little slower
right
and here you can see that the sizes have
changed and the you know i've been
orthogonalized
okay
so um the ratio of yellow to blue dots
is called the vapor fraction right this
is this idea for faber's law that
determines your accuracy from just that
ratio
um and so you can measure people's labor
fraction their ability to do this task
their kind of number precision
and what you find is first of all that
there's very big individual differences
okay
now this is interesting it's like things
that we've seen in other domains they're
very big individual differences in
navigational ability they're very big
individual differences in face
recognition ability
and
in both of those cases as well
there are people who are just so bad at
it from an early age that it's like a
syndrome in this case it's all
developmental dyscalculia
i think i didn't fit it into the
navigation lectures but there's a whole
kind of you know developmental
disability and navigation that's called
developmental topographic agnosia people
who are just always really awful at
knowing where they are right
and there's i did mention developmental
prosopagnosia people were just always
awful at face recognition in each of
these cases
in the apparent
lack of any evidence of brain damage
uh and in the absence of differences in
iq or other abilities so it seems like
each of those abilities has a very broad
range at the bottom end of the range
it's really kind of affects your life
you're so bad
and it's unrelated to other abilities
and i think that's pretty interesting
because it goes along with the idea that
those mental abilities are really
distinct parts of mind and brain you can
have a crappy number sense and it
doesn't mean that you're
bad at other things you just have a
crappy number some sense it's a separate
system right
okay
um
approximate number sense develops slowly
it's best at age 30 you guys are still
on the upswing we won't talk about me
um this is um what do we have here this
is vapor fraction so the vapor fraction
is you know what that ratio needs to be
for you to be fairly accurate
on whatever criteria they chose and so a
small fraction means you're better and
so it goes down and this is age here
i'm fast at 30 and this is reaction time
which goes up for everything
what about room anyway
um
interestingly early ability with
approximate number as on this kind of a
test predicts later math ability with
very different kinds of organized you
know
math that you learn in school
so here's a here's a study that looked
at that they asked whether this early
approximate number sense is predictive
of later arithmetic ability and so in
this case they did a task like this and
their measure what they didn't use the
task i just showed you this is another
thing you can do with little kids you
just flash this up and you just ask them
how many dots are there and they have to
say four right you just measure reaction
time it's pretty basic
okay
and so then what you do is you run this
on kindergartners
and you define groups that are slow
medium or fast at this task
okay
so then you follow them and you look at
them later in this case at age nine year
nine and six years
and what you see is even these older
kids
um who are defined by the slow medium or
fast group in kindergarten this is now
their accuracy at arithmetic tasks four
years later
yeah
so it's not just some weird little task
that psychophysicists made up
to measure god knows what it's
predictive of your later arithmetic
ability
okay
so it matters
so the speed of this dot estimation task
at kindergarten
is not associated with later abilities
of other kinds like raven's matrices
which is one of the standard measures in
an iq test right it's a non-verbal
um and non-number kind of task
or ability to name digits or letters or
other things that you can test kids on
in
however old they are nine years
okay
so it's specifically predictive of later
arithmetic ability everybody with me so
it matters
all right
um and that suggests that like you know
there would be ways to intervene in
dyscalculia potentially you could catch
the kids early who are destined to have
a hard time and maybe figure out what
you could do about it and their efforts
underway to do that okay
okay
um
okay so
i'm gonna show you uh we're exploring
these various number abilities i'm gonna
show you something interesting about
symbolic numbers so far we've been
talking about non-symbolic numbers that
means just dot arrays now we're going to
deal with symbolic numbers i'm going to
flash up a bunch of numbers
and you're just going to say bigger if
it's bigger than 65 or smaller if it's
smaller than 65
really easy but you're going to shout it
out loud and clear ready
here we go
[Music]
okay did you guys see what happened
there
did you feel what happened
when the numbers get closer to 65 you're
slower
now you think about it why the hell is
that
right if you run this in matlab it's not
going to take longer to tell you that 63
is smaller than 65
than it takes to tell you that 8 is
smaller than
65. right i assume i haven't tried it
but i doubt it
so what does that mean
that means that even when you are
dealing with symbolic numbers numbers
that you have this whole elaborate
edifice you've been trained on how to
operate with these guys especially you
guys
you are still
invoking some kind of notion of the
continuous quantity you haven't totally
left that idea behind and moved off into
some
abstract space you're still
even in doing this very
literal
exact symbolic
number task
you find it easier when the numbers are
farther apart than when they're closer
yeah
um be because of like the number you
chose so like if you chose the number 16
outside
like i feel like people read left to
right and they maybe have a good concept
for like the number of digits that they
see so like
when we see a number like 62 we have to
kind of like read both the digits
instead of like just the one yeah but
all the ones i showed were at least two
digits
yeah but like
when you read like when you see a number
like 25 like you see like the two and
then you automatically like know that
okay fair enough okay that's a good
counter counter explanation but you guys
were slow even with 58
um
i think
right we could test that i'm pretty sure
all this has been tested pretty
carefully i don't know this literature
you know
totally thoroughly but i i doubt it's a
good alternative account and there might
be some effect but i think it's oh in
fact in fact actually there is yes i
have data coming up next
vote right blah blah okay here's the
data
okay
it's pretty continuous
so i think
your your good plausible alternative
doesn't seem to capture very much of it
okay
so
um
so yeah this is what you guys just did
and does everybody get how this kind of
reveals that even when you think you're
doing this kind of more
symbolic abstract thing you're still
tapping into some kind of continuous
notion
yeah
okay
so that says not only does your ability
to do that in kindergarten predict
predict your ability to do arithmetic
later it says even now as highly trained
mit students who do all kinds of much
more sophisticated math than this you're
still invoking that same kind of
continuous sense of approximate number
or something like it
okay
all right um so where have we gotten we
started with this checklist of what
number sense might mean
and i've argued that you know you adults
can represent large numerical magnitudes
without verbal counting
but these numbers are approximate and
that your ability to discriminate them
depends on the ratio not the difference
um and i've
sort of loosely told you that these
experiments are generally done
unconfounded from things like area um
and that they uh refer to the discrete
number okay what about these other
questions here i haven't really shown
you how abstract they are
uh or whether you can actually use them
in arithmetic operations okay so how
would we tell that well here's an
experiment that we did way back we did
the very same task i did on you guys
before which has more
except the first thing was an array of
dots and the second thing was a series
of tones
okay
series of tones presented faster than
you could count
like that right
okay
and so you might think that if people
are doing some literal perceptual thing
that this would be just like freaking
impossible
right
but it's not
accuracy is just about the same maybe a
hair lower but almost the same with the
cross modal comparison of which has more
than when the within modality one of
visual to you know dots to dots or tones
to tones because dots to dots and tones
to tones and that's a cross
it's a little bit surprising
so that shows you that whatever you're
tapping into is a pretty abstract
representation it's not tied to vision
it's not tied to hearing and it also
completely eliminates worries about
density or area or stuff like that
because that doesn't work here at all
okay
all right
um
okay can you do operations on these
sure why not you can give people a dot
array and a dot array and then tell them
to add and ask whether the sum of those
is greater or less than that
let's try it
okay here we go everyone ready
consider is the sum of this
plus this
greater or less than this
yeah
okay
and i really didn't leave you time to
count
and so whatever you were doing in adding
you weren't adding symbolic numbers you
were adding these approximate amounts
okay well done
and then we could go crazy and do it
across modalities i got to ask you to
add dots to tones and ask whether the
sum is greater or less than that
we won't do it
but
turns out people are just as good at
that
amazing huh
so where has this gotten us it's told us
that whatever this approximate number
sense that we all have
it's damned abstract you can compare it
across sensory modalities pretty much as
well as within
and you can perform operations with it
you can do addition and you can also do
subtraction just as straightforwardly
okay
so that's pretty cool
but
in all of these studies and the demos
with you guys these are done on people
with years and years of training and
arithmetic
and so we really want to know are these
things is any aspect of the system
innate is it present in very young
infants and to what extent do animals
have these abilities
okay
well how would we find out whether
they're present in infants
uh well there's a bunch of ways but
looking direction and looking time are
the key cues you have with newborn
infants and so here's a study that was
done on four day old infants
and what they did was they presented
um
they presented they had a
familiarization phase this is done cross
modally okay so they present either sets
of twelve sounds two two two two twelve
right of those or ra
ra present a bunch of those to infants
or they present sets of four taking the
same total duration two
two
it's just a coincidence that it's two
this is i think done in french so anyway
the infants won't be confused by the
sound too
um so af so
um during that
you then show
uh the infants these arrays
and you ask what they look at more
okay
i mean they're not told a task there's
no way to tell them a task it's just
something they do
and what you find is
in the um
four versus twelve case like here that's
4 versus 12.
the infants look more at the congruent
number
than the incongruent number
okay so again they're comparing across
modality they're hearing some number of
syllables
and they're selectively looking at the
corresponding number of visual
forms
no instruction no nothing four days old
amazing
okay
so they can do that if the comparison is
four versus 12
they can do it if it's 6 versus 18
but they kind of can't do it very well
and it's significant but it's not very
good if it's 4 versus 8.
okay so they have some sense of number
but it's very approximate yeah did you
see if you watch the one that matches
the number or the open sound that
doesn't matter that matches that's a
congruent means match
looking time on congruent versus income
isn't that like kind of different
from adaptation
it is it is totally different from
adaptation and herein lies a a a classic
annoyance for developmental
psychologists because sometimes
kids match and sometimes they show
adaptation
and it's um you kind of don't know
sometimes you don't know which way it's
going to go
um
i don't know heather do we have any
insights about how you know which way
it's going to go or you just try and
experiment you find out and yeah
yeah yeah it does mean you have to be
careful because if you run a whole
experiment on a smallish number of
infants and it's usually hard to get
enough because people have to drive in
with their kids and this how do you find
them and there's other developmental
labs who have all the kids and it's like
so you're always running experiments
with barely enough kids right
um and so that means there's a problem
here because
if you would take the result in either
direction
that's a statistical problem you gave
yourself two shots at it right and so
you have to statistically discount
um your finding because it could have
gone either way like that is if your
prior hypothesis is it has to go in one
direction you're on stronger footing but
you just suck it up and run a few more
kids
yeah
okay
so um
good so so this also shows that ratio
dependence
right they're better at it with the big
differences than the small differences
okay
um
okay so that's infants having this very
very early at least in very crude form
um
what about animals okay so let's meet
mercury the macaw
here's mercury the macaw
to a human the order of the symbols
shown on the above screen are obvious
you have all learned from the young age
oh what a good birdie
and which the highest
however for mercury the blue head of the
call we see here
he has had to learn by trial and error
the specific order to press these
symbols to get a piece of food
it took him quite a long time
mercury's brother mars can do a bit
better than that
he has begun to learn the more general
concept that is the symbols will always
have an order
so when presented with a new list he was
able to rapidly decipher the all of the
new symbols in this case kingfisher
warhead or
hummingbird pressing randomly on the
screen would have led to him receiving
the correct answer less than one percent
of the time and he's clearly doing
better than that
this is interesting as it shows the very
basic aspects of cognition related to
numbers are present in an animal that is
very distantly related to humans
okay mostly i just showed that because
it's cute but it's impressive ordering
okay still he's kind of slow it only
goes up to four things
okay so now
we're gonna meet the chimp ayumu who
lives in kyoto and who's the son of a
very famous chimp named i who was like a
number whiz but anyway here's uh
here's ayumu
i know i can only like catch the first
three and then it's like i can't even
tell if he's correct except from the
tone
pretty good
[Laughter]
i got one wrong
anyway mostly get some pretty impressive
huh
okay so that's cool an order is clearly
relevant it's part of the space but it's
not the same as quantity or number right
okay
so now we're going to skip to the
honeybee
just for kicks because this paper just
came out a month ago and i think it's
awesome
um honeybees have one million neurons
and if you're impressed don't be
impressed remember like a mouse has a
hundred million and we have a hundred
billion
okay
six orders of magnitude okay so a
million is like not no
eight orders of magnitude so a million
is not that many right
okay and further these guys branched off
from us evolutionarily a very long time
ago 600 million years ago so they're
tiny little guys not very many neurons
totally different kind of thing who
would think they would have any kind of
numerical abilities
of course they wouldn't right
and yet they can do arithmetic
okay so here's the design
um so here's what these guys did this
wonderful lab in australia i love this
stuff okay so they train these honeybees
they this is a chamber like this
honeybees fly into the chamber and they
see a number in a color right here it's
blue and it's two okay
and then there's a little entry hole and
they can choose to play or not play
if they go into the
chamber then they're in this interior
space where they get to make a choice
between that pattern and that pattern
okay
and there's a little pole underneath
each pattern and if they light and they
land on the pole they can get some
liquid okay so in the blue case
they're rewarded over trials that if
it's blue that means they should add one
to this number and hence that would be
the correct answer and that's the
incorrect answer
okay
pretty amazing yeah
um and if they choose the wrong number
they get some nasty um quinine okay
all right
in contrast
if the shape out front is yellow then
they have to subtract
so that means they have to keep track of
this number and go in there and choose
that number minus one right
okay
so keep in mind oh so they balance the
total surface area it doesn't look like
this in this figure but it says in the
method section they did i believe them
and further
realize that when the b is in here he
has to be holding that number in memory
and adding one to it or subtracting one
to it to figure out what to choose here
so this is pretty sophisticated it's not
like they're side by side right
okay and yet
they're pretty good at it
here's accuracy over training trials by
100 trials they're over 80 percent
correct
pretty amazing isn't it
okay so then
in any good um uh animal or infant
cognition study you want to show whether
it generalizes so then they test the
same ability with new numbers i forget
what this range was but it went you know
one to four or something like that and
then they go to five or six just to
generalize the numbers uh and different
shapes than were used in the training
trial
and the accuracy is around you know mid
60s it's not quite as good but it's
still very good they're not being
reinforced here and they're still doing
the task
now what are the pink and blue bars okay
so
um
you might think well is it bee just
going to the one that has more or less
so instead of learning add one he's
learned go to the larger number larger
than the one that you saw at the entry
chamber or go to the smaller number but
no that's not what they're doing
because
the pink bars show the performance when
both of the options are in the same
direction right so
the the thing is um
blue so he's doing addition
and he sees a two and he goes in he has
a choice between three or four
he can only do that if he knows the
difference between adding one and just
taking the thing that has more
right and
he's well above chance in the pink bars
okay so he's not just saying
you know choose the one that has more or
the one that has last he's adding one
pretty accurate i mean sort of
accurately better than chance okay
all right
now that's pretty cool
but adding one subtracting one
you know
it's cool but
do they really have abstract concepts
like do they understand the concept of
zero
okay so paper was published last year
arguing that they have the concept of
zero here's how it goes
same lab
trains them in this case just on more
greater than or less than
so the b's are given a choice like this
uh and one set of b's is trained on
greater than and one is trained on less
than so this set of b's
um trained on greater than chooses this
one and then this one and then this one
and so on okay
another set of bees is trained to do the
opposite all right
okay so that's the training phase
then we want to test
in a generalized situation so now
they're tested with different shapes
and different numbers
so threes and fours were
three and maybe threes weren't used i
forget there's some numbers in here that
were not used before okay so you try you
test them with a new shapes
and here is accuracy for less than and
great or greater than chance is 50 and
they're 75 percent not bad
okay
so they get more than or less than
okay now we want to test the
generalization
okay oh yes sorry this is where they
changed the range of numbers so the b's
had not dealt with um
sixes before
so now they still have to do greater
than and less than
um with a new numerical range
and they're still well above chance
okay
so then finally
they test zero
okay
so
the b's that have to do less than
have to say which of those is correct
right
and
you can see
where did it go
uh
where's the zero one right here
and they're well above chance for both
less than and greater
okay
so we could quibble about whether that's
a concept of zero but the cool thing is
these bees had not been tested with a
blank card before
and they
spontaneously get the idea that that is
less than one or two or three or
anything else yeah
so arguably they have a concept of zero
with no training
and only 100 million neurons
okay so all of that is uh in trained
animals and um and we can see
some of these kinds of abilities even
with untrained animals and i i will tell
you just one more animal experiment
because it's my all-time favorite ever
and the simplest one in the whole set
this is done a long time ago by church
and mec so here's what they did this is
done in rats they have a training phase
where they train the rats
to press the two lever if they see two
light flashes or hear two sounds
and they press another lever the four
lever if they see four lights or hear
four sounds
okay that's kind of basic animal
training it's a rodent they're good at
this no big deal
but then after the animals have learned
this
they spontaneously
throw in the testing phase a trial with
two lights and two sounds
and the rats press the four lever first
time no training no nothing spontaneous
addition spontaneous abstraction across
tones
and lights
pretty awesome huh
so it's not just that you can reveal
these abilities with elaborate training
okay so we have all of these different
kinds of
evidence of an abstract number sense
and they're present in newborn infants
and they're present in animals and they
just seem to be part of our basic
cognitive machinery machinery that we
share with uh with animals so how are
they implemented in the brain
um
okay so little neuro neuroanatomy
reminder of some basics this is a weird
angle of a brain it's kind of like this
kind of back of the head front of the
head temporal lobe frontal lobe around
the corner everybody oriented
there's one of the longest cell site in
the brain that starts about here on me
goes like this and it curves around like
that it's backyard goes up and occurs
over okay it's called the interpretal
sulcus
and i mentioned that just because it's
in a lot of the number literature you
saw it in the paper you guys read for
last night
um and above it it's a spirit
parietal lobule and below it is the
inferior parietal lobule none of that
matters other than that a lot of the
action is in the parietal lobe
particularly up here around the
interpretal sulcus okay
all right
so studies that have looked at this
includes
some classical studies of patients with
brain damage
uh and something called a calculia that
means loss of ability to calculate okay
and so there's um two basic kinds of
acalculia
um that are really interestingly
different so so what there's one um a
calculus patient
who has left parietal damage that same
region i just talked about
and this person is bad at approximation
so the kinds of dot array tasks that i
gave you guys
this this guy after brain damage right
here is really bad at that kind of stuff
and interestingly he's more impaired on
subtraction than multiplication
so for example he can do
he's worse at what is 7 minus 5
then what is 7 times 5
so think about that for a moment think
about what that might mean
especially in light of another a
calculus patient
who has a very different presentation
he's got left temporal damage
his approximation is fine so all those
kind of daughter ray kind of tasks and
tone tasks that i told you about he's
good at this guy shows the opposite he's
more impaired at multiplication than
subtraction
so
do you guys have any oh so first of all
you put these two patients together and
what do you have
yeah what
double dissociation right two patients
with opposite patterns of deficit right
if we just had one then we could maybe
tell a story but it wouldn't really know
but we have two and they have opposite
patterns and now that really kind of
contrains the interpretation david can
go to the first question
ah good question
um he's not very good at adam
thoughts what do you think it means
the addition subtraction
so are used what
yeah so one one hypothesis is that
addition and subtraction are just a
different beast than multiplication
different parts of the brain do those
things totally possible but there's a
kind of more intuitive interpretation
well i think people tend to memorize
times tables bingo
bingo often like the right answer is
something that's like right in front of
you just think about what is it like to
do that how do you do 7 times 5 you
don't think about the meanings of the
numbers you just blurt out 35
right right it's not very it's not a
very rich number time it's a number task
but it's a concrete wrote verbally
memorized thing
right
and so the idea is
that you know that that that those
verbalized concrete uh number facts are
you know in one domain one set of brain
damage would impair those and it's a
different thing to impair the actual
representation of numerosity and the
idea is that um
uh this person is the one with the real
damage to the approximate number system
right yeah so the step in the um that
patients can be our people these people
like during the several times five
normally but when they
asked for summing seven four five times
they're not gonna get three
yeah well i think the approximate number
system might have a tough time dealing
with
summing seven
five times so yeah you know it has
limits right it can deal with it can do
it can add two approximate things but it
might you might really lose your mind if
you tried to do the whole string of it
yeah yeah so we're trying to see if
maybe if he was working with the same
digits like maybe seven plus seven or
seven minus seven
like expensive maybe
to do that fairly easily
if that's the case right
uh say more
if it's the case that isn't possible
yeah yeah
yeah you should be able to do something
to set up fairly easy because that's
like you know that when you stop trying
the same thing you're going to be good
to go yes but it's an interesting
question actually whether that would be
part of that system or whether that's a
kind of more abstract
formal thing you learn so i think it
depends how you do it right so one of
the ways i didn't talk about this but
those same those same experiments adding
say um
adding dots to dots
those were also done with little kids
and there what you do is you show
i don't really remember what it is but
you show some array of things and you
hide it behind the screen and you show
another ray and hide it behind the
screen and then you reveal the screen
like how many things are there
that kind of stuff works spontaneously
so it might
it might tap into that system i think
that's an interesting question i'm not
totally sure how it would go
yeah so the second person is about it we
call lacrosse board or is it just with
numbers just with numbers
yeah i mean it's always a little bit
messy that patient literature is always
like some other random stuff and you can
how do you account for that and there's
lesions in other places but to a first
approximation these are reasonably
number specific deficits
right
okay so that's a bit of a hint from the
neuropsychology literature but you know
there's basically these mainly these two
patients and some other like messier
ones
um
and uh so
one wants to
use neuroimaging to get a better picture
of it of course that's been going on for
a long time and so here's one of the
early papers from stan to hens lab this
is the top view of the brain so this is
this parietal zone and this is that what
is often referred to as the horizontal
segment of the interpretal sulcus
hips to its friends and it's that sulcus
that i talked about that goes up like
this it kind of curves over it's like
this bit right there okay
that little orange strip
and so what he's saying in this review
article from a long time ago is that
that region is activated only when you
do calculation it means basic arithmetic
in this case
not when you do all these other things
but when this paper came out i'm like
yeah
right i don't think so
i can't tell you how many experiments
i've run and seen big ass activations
right there on tasks that have nothing
to do with numbers so looks good sounded
good he got away with it for a while and
it's not true yeah
high enough that you've been zapping
terrible
big film too
he's a really smart nice guy i just like
when people are a little bit fast and
loose and make a big claim which you can
tell at the time isn't quite right it's
a little bit annoying anyway sorry go
ahead yeah is the region high enough
that you can zap it
ah we're getting there yes indeed you
can
but let's do a little more basic stuff
first okay so the claim is that this
hips thing
is the locus of the approximate number
system that was the early claim okay
um
and for further the claim implicit in
this this article in this figure is that
it's involved in numerical
representations only not any of these
other things grasping tasks manual tasks
eye movement tasks etc etc etc okay
really
um and as i mentioned like me and lots
of other people had seen these same
regions see it looks like the same
regions activated in all kinds of other
situations especially those involving
reasoning about spatial location
you guys got short shrift
six weeks ago i meant to talk about the
parietal lobe and its role in high-level
vision and it just somehow went by the
boards but all this stuff is involved in
aspects of vision particularly spatial
vision knowing what is where okay
and so there's an alternate view which
is that there's no specific brain region
that's
that's specifically only involved in
discrete number per se
instead there's a common region for
processing
magnitude
of almost any dimension whether discrete
or continuous right the approximate
number system or your exact number
system
and that it builds on previous
representations of space
okay
for example the number line
right
so you guys read this article for last
night
um and just to review what the key point
was this is again
this is the the kind of aerial view with
the parietal lobe here and that's the
business the hips region yeah
um that were that we were um that was in
the previous slide and you can see it's
this horizontal part of that sulcus way
up in the parietal lobe
and the yellow and green means that
there's overlapping activation for both
symbolic calculation that's like with
symbols and for non-symbolic calculation
that's like dot arrays stuff like that
right and so it's activated for both of
those
um and um
the point of this paper uh
is first of all that there's also
overlap with eye movement system right
um
and so here they're really asking is
this spatial representation kind of
co-opted in your representation of
number using a kind of spatial number
line right it makes perfect sense you
animals need a representation of space
it's like extremely basic right and once
you have that you can co-opt it and
represent numbers in that same spatial
code
and as you guys all read the the cool
result from that paper which is also
also from stan to hen's lab
is uh that that when you take that
region right in there you take those
voxels in there and you train them on
making leftward versus rightward
saccades so now you have a classifier
that looks at the pattern of activation
there you can distinguish the left word
versus the right word versus sakad i'm
just reviewing this hopefully it was
clear enough
that same classifier
can then distinguish subtraction versus
addition did you guys all get that from
the paper yeah it's pretty cool isn't it
um anyway so that's kind of nice
evidence that the same spatial system
that's used in spatial attention and eye
movements has been co-opted
to represent
numbers as well
okay
all right
so
i just wanted to incorporate that in
case anybody missed what the paper was
about those were the key points
other other early studies have asked
more directly this question of whether
different kinds of magnitude are all
represented together in the brain
and this study is quite clever um they
used that uh a variant of the fact that
i showed you guys before remember when
saying whether number is greater or less
than 65 it's harder when it's closer to
65 than when it's farther from 65 okay
even though i was showing you symbols
that was a key thing right
so that's called the distance effect
right and that's true for all
comparisons and so this study
exploits that distance effect and they
use
stimuli like this
and they ask
which one is larger and it could be
larger in absolute size like the two is
larger here
or it can be larger in number meaning
like the seven is larger okay so in
different blocks you're saying which one
is physically larger which one is
numerically larger
which one is brighter that would be this
one here
and then um
then they just have a control with
letters
okay
and so then sorry this the design is
slightly complicated so there's these
three main tasks in a controlled task
but then within each they have the
difficult version and the easy version
and the difficult version is when the
comparisons are close two similar
brightnesses to similar numbers to
similar sizes
versus two larger ones okay so that's
all that's what all this garbage shows
okay so then you do that subtraction you
look and you say okay what parts of the
brain are more active when you do
the difficult versus easy number
comparison
like saying which is larger
it's not that difficult but you know two
verses three
versus two versus seven
okay
um
and so what they find
is that similar regions of the brain are
active for all three of those kinds of
comparisons
okay so it's not like you get
just one for symbolic number or for the
or or for the the two magnitude tasks
all of those different kinds of
magnitude activate the same
regions
and
and so
the conclusion is that number and size
in gay and brightness engage a common
parietal spatial code okay an
overlapping region for all of these does
that make sense
okay
um
and so that shows in this case that it's
not just
symbolic number
but also
magnitude which one is bigger
right that's a kind of continuous
magnitude idea
okay
okay
right so one worry
is that in each of these cases they're
comparing a difficult condition to an
easy condition
and so maybe the regions they got are
just engaged in any kind of task
difficulty
maybe if they had done a
syntactically you know a syntactic task
on language stimuli that was difficult
versus easy they would get the same
things from this experiment we don't
know we'll talk more about that in a
couple weeks when we talk about language
right
um
but here's at least one control
that deals with that sort of and which
does a tms experiment as you suggested a
while back
okay so this is kind of cool experiment
i mean it's weird but sort of cool
okay so what do they do they use um okay
so they have
again an easy task and a hard task
um again it's you know it's the thing
greater or less than 65
you know not very hard right the hard
one is that hard but um so is it greater
or less than 65 and it's either
a
symbolic number or it's a dot array you
can't really see it but there's a bunch
of teeny dots in there
uh or in the other condition they have
to say
whether that ellipse is more horizontal
or vertical okay
and so you spend a lot of time before
you run the experiment measuring
reaction time and accuracy to
balance difficulty within the easy
conditions and balance difficulty within
the hard conditions
okay so then what they do is they do
something called offline tms okay
offline tms i didn't talk about this
much much before
the the standard kinds of tms you stick
the coil right on the subject's head
there's you know a subject doing a task
on a monitor and somebody's standing
there holding the coil it's really kind
of rudimentary
and right at a key point of the trial
you deliver a zap to disrupt that part
of the brain and you find out how much
that interferes with performance on that
task that's the standard online kind of
tms thing
but there's also offline tms
where you zap people at a slow rate for
like 10 minutes
and then the idea is that you've kind of
generally disrupted that piece of brain
for say another 10 minutes it's a little
bit scarier but just like 10 minutes
right
okay and so that way you don't have to
be quite so fancy about the precise
timing you can just kind of
reduce its effectiveness for a whole 10
minutes okay so that's what they did
here offline tms so you sit there and
get zapped for 10 minutes slowly here
and then you like do some math tasks
okay
okay so what they find is that
zapping the left interparietal sulcus
disrupts the magnitude tasks on both
numbers and dots
but it doesn't mess up the shape tasks
with the ellipses even though the
ellipses are balanced for difficulty
okay
so that's at least a little bit of an
argument that it's not just about
generic difficulty at least in this
experiment
okay
all right
i think that's what i just said so um
that's yeah some evidence for a role of
at least the left inner parietal sulcus
and both symbolic and non-symbolic
number again non-symbolic number just
means dots without arabic numbers
not just any difficulty all right
so that's all very nice but it's crude
as hell right we found these big blurry
chunks of brain that are implicated and
we zapped a big chunk of brain and
slightly reduced performance it's like
okay better than nothing but it's not
very impressive what are the actual
neurons doing in the brain
well now it becomes really important and
useful
that
this approximate number system that i've
been talking about is also present in
animals
and that means we can use animal models
and we can record from individual
neurons in the parietal lobes of monkeys
when they do number tasks to find out
what actual neurons are doing
okay
and so there's a guy named andreas
nieder who's been doing this for a long
time
and he has some pretty remarkable data
and so
he starts by training monkeys to do a
number task so here's what the monkey
sees monkey sees a sample with some
number of dots
and then there's a memory delay in this
case one second then he has to do a
matching task and choose that array not
this array
okay so we've got to remember that
there's three dots and choose the right
three and notice that the sizes and
configuration of the dots have changed
so we have to do something more like
remember three in whatever
mental monkeyes version of three exists
okay
okay simple matching tasks
um then he records from neurons in the
parietal and frontal cortex in monkeys
and he finds neurons that are sort of
specific for number
okay so here's time in that task
this is the time that the sample is
presented right here
and here is a the response of a single
neuron
that likes two
more than anything else
okay
and that two notice is all different
kinds of spatial arrangements and sizes
of the dots
what's common about all of them is that
it's two
next best it likes four
okay and it generalizes across number
from there so it's approximate it's not
like high for two and zero for
everything else it's got a kind of
generalization gradient
um but it prefers to
okay so that's a number neuron
yeah
okay
um
here's a here's a sixth neuron
that's neuron like six
um here it is same task during
presentation of trials here
red is six
uh next closest is like eight and maybe
ten so it also generalizes as well but
it responds more to 6 than anything else
pretty awesome huh
okay
now
that doesn't tell us how it was computed
right so you know finding a single
neuron that does something spectacular
is thrilling we all love it it's great
fun
um and we're closer to the neural
circuit because we found a neuron that
seems to be part of the action but
notice it doesn't tell us how that
neuron made that computation right
what are the circuits that led into it
that enabled it to be specific to six or
two
um but it's still cool
okay but next we want to know how
abstract are those neurons this is just
you know dot arrays okay
uh and they're just presented
in one array
so next
andreas needer trains his monkeys to
keep track of the number of things that
happen over time it's not a spatial
array it's a temporal sequence
okay so he has to see that there's four
things
coming in here
and then choose the array that matches
with four
okay
see how this is a way to ask how
abstract those those number neurons are
are they really representing the
abstract magnitude of two or six or
whatever it is or are they representing
something about the shape of a two type
array or a six type array
okay
um and they can also test over different
modalities so now they present four
different tones and the monkey has to
choose the four dots
okay now it's both over time and over
sensory modality
so how abstract are those numbered
neurons okay they're pretty abstract
so here are a few number neurons cell
one is in the blue colors and here is
its response uh in light blue to dots
one dot two dot three dots four dots
and here is the same cell responding to
um sounds
it's specific to one
both for sounds and for data rays
that cool
and you see the green the green cell is
selective for two
whether in dots or sounds
and so forth
pretty cool
so these are very abstract number
neurons
does that make sense
okay
um okay
um
okay now these monkeys are trained on
number tasks
so you might think that these kinds of
abstract number neurons and they're
trained to do the generalization from
tones to arrays so maybe those number
neurons wouldn't live in their brains if
they hadn't been trained to do that
um but i don't have time to show you all
the data but in subsequent work
uh the same team has found among has
recorded for monkeys before any training
and you find similar number neurons
so it does seem like these are you know
things that exist in monkey and remember
that's consistent with what i said
before which is that
a lot of these um a lot of these number
abilities are present in animals without
any training and in newborns and so it
makes sense that some of those neurons
would be around even in advance of any
training neurons that they have to look
at to find oh that's a good question i
forget what percent it is we could look
it up in the neater paper yeah um it's
not like you record from thousands and
you find ten right
um
remember they know where to look from
the first the human lesion literature
and then the human functional imaging
literature and then there's also
monkey neuroimaging literature where you
can have monkeys doing dot tasks so you
can you can know where to look because
you know the brain's a big place if
you're just sticking electrodes all over
god help you right so they know to go up
in that parietal lobe if that region is
homologous between humans and monkeys
and there's a lot of other evidence that
that region is homologous
um so they know how to get in the right
zone and i'm sure once in the right zone
they're not all number neurons i'm sure
it's a relatively small percent but it's
not
trivial percent
yeah and do we have sense for how
fractions are represented because all
these seem to be sort of discrete
over the individual
any ideas
yeah well it's tricky because
it's certainly at the single unit level
you'd have to either find some natural
version where monkeys think about
fractions naturally
or teach them about fractions which
would be really hard because for some
reason fractions are just really hard
like all the all the people who study
math education
it's like the key problem is how do you
get kids to understand fractions i don't
know why they're such a such a tough
thing but apparently it's like a real
dividing line the kids who get fractions
of the kids who don't
so i'd have to think for
but you know
occasionally there are patients with
electrodes
uh in their brains and one could look at
that
actually
actually
i took this slide out but there's a
recent a paper that came out last year
where they found number neurons in
humans as well
i took it out because i didn't know how
to integrate it in the lecture because
the number neurons are deep in the
medial temporal lobe far from the
parietal lobe i was like i don't know
how that fits i don't know if that's the
same thing or something else but anyway
there are at least some number neurons
that have been found in humans
and you could in principle look for
number neurons
up in the parietal lobe
um in fact i have a
a guy i'm trying to collaborate with i'm
begging him to collaborate with me he's
got two people who have a raise of
electrodes chronically implanted
right up in this region here
um because they are paralyzed they had
spinal damage and like michael cohen's
lecture he's got um arrays of electrodes
where he's trying to use the neural
responses there to direct robot arms
and so there's two of these people who
have these chronically implanted things
i'm like oh please please please can i
collaborate with you and get responses
from your your your patience neurons was
there a question over here a moment ago
sorry i thought i saw him
um
okay so let me wrap up um so i've been
arguing that this approximate number
system
is shared with animals and newborns it's
a pretty basic system that lots of
animals have
it follows weber's law which you should
remember i don't like testing you guys
on esoteric facts but weber's law is a
very fundamental fact and you should
know it
about perception and in particular about
number it tells you that the ability to
discriminate two numbers goes as the
ratio not as the difference
of those numbers
and that these uh approximate magnitude
representations measured both
behaviorally and neurally in humans and
animals
are very abstract to the particular
objects to the modality to whether they
come in over space or time
etc whether they're represented in
symbols or arrays of items okay
um i mentioned that there are big
individual differences in humans in the
precision of the approximate number
system
and that is predictive of
later arithmetic abilities independent
of iq
and we talked about the horizontal
segment of the interpretal sulcus as a
key
locus for the
approximate number system
in humans
including number specific neurons
and we also talked about both in some of
the papers i mentioned and the paper
you guys read that
there seems to be that that approximate
number system up here in the parietal
lobe
so far doesn't seem to be one of these
extremely specialized systems like
faces and motion and navigation
which may turn out to be less
specialized later with pending more data
but which at the moment we can already
see that these number representations
overlap a lot with representations of
space
shown perhaps most dramatically in the
paper you guys read showing cross
decoding
between eye movement direction and
arithmetic operations okay
hang on once i'm almost done summing up
number neurons we talked about that
uh yes so we'll give the last word to
stand ahead who started off with this
very extreme view and has evolved to a
still interesting but slightly less
extreme view
he says the brain treats number like a
specific category of knowledge
requiring its own neurological apparatus
and the parietal lobe
but when it comes to subtler
distinctions such as number versus
length space or time
the specificity of hips vanishes
no part of hips appears to be involved
in numerical computations alone
in fact he goes further to say that the
human brain in general is neither
anisotropic white paper like
equi-potential
where all the regions are equivalent nor
a neat arrangement of tightly
specialized and well-separated modules
right anyway okay there was a question
sorry i just wanted to talk about
childhood ams updating later lately
just
then having this um
i guess
easier time with approximately numbers
give them like more of an interesting
problem
that's a really really good question
and i am sure there are data on that and
i don't know what they are but i will go
look i always say that but i dana will
you send me an email right now to go
look up
whether the prediction from childhood
ans to adult
arithmic
arithmetic abilities has to do with an
interest or you might say
just an emotional response like if you
suck at it it feels bad and you become
avoidant and you get all dysfunctional
about it right
um we all have i mean most of us have
domains where we do that
um
and you know math phobia is a real thing
and who knows it could start in there so
yeah good good question i don't know i
will look that up
other questions
okay see you guys on wednesday
you